sind da draußen noch mehr Leute
erschlagen von der Gartenplanung ich
stecke hier gerade mitten in einem
wilden organisationss und planungsabend
und deswegen dachte ich mir teile ich
euch mal was mit was euch vielleicht
freut und zwar habe ich ein Pflanzplan
für euch ausgeklügelt der kostet kein
Geld den könnt ihr euch einfach auf
meiner Webseite herunterladen den Link
findet ihr auf meinem Profil aber ihr
könnt auch einfach mal Wurzelwerk
Pflanzplan googeln dann kommt ihr auch
auf die Seite wo ihr euch den
runterladen könnt muss ja darauf achten
wer wächst nebeneinander vertragen sich
die Gemüsepflanzen überhaupt wie viel
Platz brauchen die im betet wie lasse
ich das betet am besten so aus dass ich
rund ums Jahr ernten kann und die beste
Ernte aus meinen beten raushole diese
ganzen Sachen habe ich schon für euch
ausgeklügelt also da müsst ihr euch
keinen Kopf mehr zerbrechen ich erkläre
euch im Plan auch wie ihr Gemüse gegen
andere austauschen könnt wenn ihr
vielleicht einen anderen Geschmack habt
als ich ich habe meinen ausgedruckt aber
ich habe den auch auf dem Handy
gespeichert weil das super praktisch ist
wenn ich gerade im Garten Wurst und mir
das ja nicht alles auswendig